joining me now uh on zoom just moments
after
one of the most intense episodes of hard
knocks
aired uh on hbo and that's saying a lot
about the history of that great series
entering his
tenth season in the national football
league after being undrafted out of
kansas by denver now with the los
angeles charges
chris harris how are you chris i'm doing
great man
cam's going great everything's good okay
um
what's it like to watch an episode of
your life about
you you were prominently featured in
episode three with your family and your
four girls and
you know um what what is it like
watching your
your professional life in a little bit
of your personal life put on hbo
chris i think it's cool man just to have
this opportunity to be on hard knocks
and then kind of
um let people see another side of me and
uh when i'm when i'm away from the
football field
they say i'm a i'm a husband i'm a
father of four kids
so they kind of get to know me outside
of the helmet
and so i just think it's a good
opportunity for that man so i thought it
was cool
yeah so let's get to the episode that we
both just watched
and the conversation that uh
tarad taylor led that was you know we
only saw
we we heard the audio we didn't see the
video of it
walk me through what he did and and
why uh everything uh went that way on
that day when
a scrimmage was supposed to be on nfl
network it seemed yeah
we just uh guys minds weren't in it all
the way
to play football game or play it was
really going to be a game so just
coach didn't feel like um guys minds
were all the way in it
and he didn't want us to go out go out
there and play ball
and when when he knew our minds weren't
right and
tyrod just got everybody together and
just wanted to
everybody express their thoughts you
know because even
even before um that killing had happened
with jacob blake i thought
that would be a good idea even as a team
just to do that you know
to kind of discuss with everything
that's going on and how they feel and
things like that so
um it was a good opportunity for guys to
express their feelings and
to get kind of anything they had off
their off their plate
and um and to really explain um
where we can try to go uh make some
changes you know
and what's going on and so that's really
what it was about it's fine finding ways
that
we can make an impact where do things
stand right now chris harris i mean
um you know i i spoke to emmanuel
sanders of the saints last week and
asked him if there would be
a sit down if there was a preseason game
he he said he didn't think so because
there were
jobs on the line and they teammates
wouldn't want to
prevent younger guys from getting a gig
i spoke to melvin gordon just earlier
this week
um uh now he's with your other team i
guess you guys both switch teams
yeah in a way he's from kenosha
wisconsin and
he said that um essentially all
concepts about maybe not playing a game
are still on the table
where where do things stand are are you
or any of your teammates talking about
maybe not playing
a game in the nfl similar to what the
nba did for some of the playoffs
uh no not right now uh we haven't
discussed that on the chargers that was
um that wasn't that that didn't come out
at all but i just know that we're
focusing on getting ready for the
bengals
uh we all in on just playing ball and
and also being able to make an impact
doing both
we feel like we're uh type of people
that we can handle doing both
you know we don't have to quit um doing
our job
and uh and feeding our family
you know and and and not be able to help
uh our community so we can still help
our people and still play
chris harris here on the rich eisen show
um we're recording this just moments
after hard knocks aired uh on tuesday
night justin herbert's looked really
good on this
uh this series chris uh but taylor
terrad
sounded sounded like the leader of this
team uh i wonder where
what's your concept of the the
quarterback situation going into week
one against cincinnati
i think tyrod's definitely um he's
definitely shown great leadership um
he's
been that uh he's been making a lot of
plays i can't lie
so herbert has two it's it's really a
great battle
um he's uh tyrod will kind of get away
and then herbert will kind of creep back
up and make some more plays so it's a
great battle i like the way
um uh herbert plays i like the way he
can throw the football he can run
he's doing better at uh with the
protections and reading the blitzes and
things like that so
uh he just he he still has some growth
and he's going to continue to get better
and i think tyrod is a great person
to kind of um welcome him into the
league he's a great vet
and uh derwin james being lost for the
year chris
i mean uh how does that affect the back
end there
with you man it definitely hurts man you
can def it's hard to replace a guy like
darwin james but
um on this team man we got a lot of we
got a lot of great depth
we i feel like um uh just being so deep
at the safety position in the corner
position our backups
can come in and and be able to do their
job so
um not sarah adelie right now desmond
king
those guys can um definitely come in and
still make plays
so um anthony lynn your your impressions
of uh of your new coach
and that was i mean you want to talk
about a shocking way for hard knocks to
begin
i mean episode one where he told uh the
team that he had uh
covet 19. i guess the first thing first
since i'm asking you tons of questions
how is he feeling did he
is he doing all right pretty much oh
yeah he said he's doing great man he's
feeling great and um
uh he's been a great coach so far you
know
um being able to uh help help me
come here you know it's a new team we
didn't get no otas
right well i kind of miss um a lot of
the off-season and
just to be able to welcome welcome in
and be able to
just come in with a clear mind uh feel
confident about what they're doing with
me
and he's made it easy for me so i love
the way he's
approached the team um he has almost
respect from other
other players you know me coming in new
i want to see how the players
you know respect how they act towards
the coach you know and you can
you can see man he has the most respect
uh so he's just going out trying to go
out there and get some wins for him
sure uh chris harris here on the rich
eisen show if i told you
on that late july day in 2011
when you got a call uh to sign with
denver as an unrestrict as an undrafted
free agent
that you'd see a tenth season in the
league what would you say what would you
say
i'd be surprised man but i knew i could
play man because i started all
um all my years in college in the big 12
and i played a lot against these guys
that are in the nfl
so i knew i could play it was just
getting that right spot that right
fit and i mean a lot of these guys uh
it's gonna be hard for these young guys
to make the team but
the good thing they have going is that
they got 16 practice squad spots
so you got a better chance to kind of
hang around that way right
so um hopefully uh some of these guys
are able to make that and uh
find their way to creep in the league so
yeah i mean you've seen it all
from being undrafted to now a tenth
season to winning a super bowl to being
in the pro bowl
four times as you have and now uh
you are encountering something that is
first for everyone which is playing in
covet 19.
do you think i'm asking you everyone the
same question but you're again
now a 10-year vet do you think that the
nfl
will be able to with the protocols
everything all set up make it through
a 17 week regular season
honestly i really uh that's a hard
answer right there
i would say probably about 60 chance you
know
with um with hopefully a lot of teams
and coaches don't spread it you know
i can see some games getting delayed or
something like that happening later on
in the season
but um as we're going now everything's
been going great
you know i feel safe because i get
tested every day
you feel safe around everybody in the
building because they're tested and they
can't come in the building unless
they pass the test you know so as long
as everybody around the league continue
to stay on this protocol stay on this
way nba's been able to finish it and be
successful yeah so i think uh if we stay
on the same path that we're on i think
we can finish the year
well i know again uh so much is made of
well young players might go out
and you know hit bars and or clubs or
uh live the life of a young um nfl
player and that might be an issue but
then there's
the other end of the spectrum i mean you
and i are both enjoying the zoom i've
enjoyed your company many times you've
been on my show chris but let's be
honest
uh the two of us are enjoying this
because we're hiding from our small
children
yeah not four i have three right now
they could come bursting
at any moment but i bring this up
because
you know you've got vectors i'm
imagining they're they're going to go to
school or they might be home school you
know they might be home zooming or
something like that but you've got
family
and there's lots of vectors coming into
your life i mean how concerned are you
uh about you and your ability to stay
uh removed from anything you might not
know is in your house or being
brought into your house or you're
bringing it into your house anything
like that
yeah i know um that's that's why i want
to do homeschool for my kids you know to
be able to
eliminate that risk because uh you can't
get it from
children you know children can pass the
virus easy so
them being in school uh being around
other kids you know
uh i i'm trying to eliminate that rule
so within my family i try to
find different ways that we can
eliminate that if it's um
picking up the food or you know what i
mean or just cooking more at home just
i think um that's the way i'm trying to
eliminate it and uh only thing it sucks
it hurts the date nights with the
i wifey you i hear but it's like you're
not living in a bubble
at least not yet they might bubble up
for the playoffs if you're fortunate to
get it
uh and then you mentioned you mentioned
the nba um
so the lakers are uh as you and i are
currently
sitting here right now waiting to find
out who they're playing in the next
round that's your team
i know you want them to wear the black
mamba jerseys for the rest of the
campaign i saw that tweet are you
concerned at all about the clippers are
you concerned about uh
the rest of this journey for your lakers
chris i'm hoping the thunder win you
know because i want to play the thunder
i feel like
uh we can sweep them boys oh you think
so huh
you can take chris cp3 at a pretty big
game six though chris i mean those
things happen
it's different man when lebron and a.d
they got a that's a different monster
for them so
um i think we we can finally we can get
some good things that
okay okc is doing versus the rockets if
we have to meet up with them
uh their defense has been kind of sloppy
and had a lot of turnover so
i'm interested to see he was gonna win
this game because i don't think
russell's all the way back from his
injury
no way i know horton has to have a big
game so
i'm interested to see uh this is going
to be a big game it's a lot of pressure
on the rockets because
owner you know the gm all those guys
mike d'antoni uh that's a lot of
pressure on hardin
you're in the game seven versus your
whole team you gotta win you're trying
to speak
lakers okc into existence i see what
you're doing right now but then there's
the the clippers waiting i mean that
would be
a heck of a western conference finals
would be late yeah
it has to be clippers versus the lakers
in the western conference finals uh
seeing lebron vs kawhi um i think we'll
go
that'll definitely go seven so uh that's
what that's what the world needs that's
what we need
chris um congrats on um your new digs
congrats on season ten i appreciate you
coming on uh
late after uh hard knocks airing um
again it was just really intense to see
uh inside these
conversations about the real world
crashing into the sports world and
stay healthy stay safe have a great
season we'll chat soon thank you rich
you got it that's chris harris of the
los angeles chargers right here on the
rich eisen show